how much was the first check my minimum
was like 430,000 checks were like 19,000
it was 16 games and then you get paid
every two games and it's just direct
deposit yep just big checks I'm like oh
I didn't know that was real money what
about for your other teammates is it
typical that they spend just a ton of
money in general or are people
smartening up a little bit now for the
most part the bankrupt I feel like that
was so old school back in the day it
wouldn't be that hard but it would be
really hard to spend our minimum now I
think minimum is like $7 $800,000 also
now something that we've done is and
instead of getting paid eight times huge
fat checks now we get paid 34 times so
now your checks are significantly
smaller so it kind of helps you kind of
budget throughout the rest of the
offseason as well